also we lose the Innovation that comes
with having Manufacturing in your
country when you have the all of the
factories your innovating processes just
like we did we you know Ford created the
assembly line like Ford or don't like
Ford he created the assembly line we're
not doing any kinds of innovation like
that at this point because we're not
doing any of the manufacturing I'd like
to see drone Manufacturing in space
because like when you have low gravity
you can have 100 million drones all
working in Synergy on a machine moving
pieces of metal together and so size is
almost Irrelevant in construction you
can just be space force should get on
that dude this is a huge space Fleet
that'd be awesome this image is is
really important to understand uh what's
going on what the dangers are
bioaccumulation so a contaminant gets in
the soil or the dirt or whatever the
plants absorb some of it as they grow
the insects will eat those plants the
birds will eat the insects and then
eventually at the higher level the food
that we eat will be heavily contaminated
with these chemicals